hey Richard pipes author of Dixie
memoirs of a non belong ER what's this
non belong are saying we're not belong
as a legal term used in the visit Virgin
Islands where we have a house and
distinguishes be longers who are
residents and property owners and
visitors who just come temporarily from
people like us who have property there
but don't belong and I meant it was
meant to emphasize that I've never
belonged 20 school of thought and I've
always been contrarian vixy means what I
have lived why don't you pick that what
I picked it because it's short and it
never used by anybody some people
misinterpret it to mean Vinci that I
have conquered which it does not mean
it's just me fighting lived you spent
most of your life where Oh in the United
States I left Poland at the age of 16
but we're in the United States in
cambridge i arrived here 1940 i went to
college right away in Ohio spent two and
a half years there then three years in
the Air Force and then I came to
Harvard's in 46 state their visits and
you spend how many years in Washington
working for Ron Reagan two years what
steam be a team B was an experiment
started in 1976 by then head of the CIA
George Bush that's not a complicated
story we had as you as you probably know
this theory of mutual assured
destruction which held it nuclear
weapons are good for nothing except
determines and according to this theory
once you reach the parity there was no
point building up any more forces
because you reach Paris you could just
you could inflict unacceptable damage on
your own you an enemy and yet the
Russians have been reached parity with
us in 1969-70 kept on building nuclear
weapons so the question arose whether
they shared our view of it and I was
asked to gather a team of experts look
at the evidence which is CIA had to see
the Russians indeed have the same
realized video but our team arrived at a
different conclusion maybe that they
have a war winning and were fighting
strategy what year did you arrive at
this there was the end of 76 just before
Jimmy Carter became president you tell a
story in your book
about team a and Team B and finding
yourself at the CIA when George Bush was
head of the CIA yeah was that well that
was all at the end of service to head
teammate in the summer of 76 and team a
was the CIA group which arrived at
certain conclusions about Soviet
strategic weapons team be where we
outsiders so the unique experiment i
think was never happened before or after
we were asked to look at the same
evidence and see if you are ever the
same conclusions and we did not and how
did George Bush treat you well he was
very cool to us because he was a very
difficult situation hehe brought us in
and we criticize his agency the agency
which she was head sort of loyalty to
his people he had to be rather cruel to
us he didn't deny that our conclusions
were correct but he wasn't really warm
too and see that it seemed to be what
some of this book is about what you
learned being an insider for two years
and the Reagan administration and these
other activities around it is you're a
way to sum up your philosophy of what
it's like to be a part of government
well to be part of government first of
all you realize that you're part of a
team I got into trouble very early
because I spoke my mind I'm used as a
professor to say what I want and I'm not
used to someone interpreting my words as
being contrary to accept in wisdom which
in this case was the administration's
wisdom I found this very difficult
secondly what you're learning government
how our talk many of the decisions are
made you know when people tend to think
that all these decisions that result of
great look pondering and and and
evidence searching and so on but
sometimes the most important decisions
are made us at hawk because people get
angry or people want to achieve
something which lated at this moment
think is desirable and thirdly I learned
to put an enormous role personalities
play you know likes and dislikes when I
was watching President Reagan and
Alexander Haig and I could see a tension
and so it was a matter of policy it was
much of personalities and that
throughout the government I noticed this
to be a factor what was the impact of
the Alexander Haig when he was secretary
of state and
rain what was the impact to the
difference in their personalities in I
mean I'm policy you you mean yeah it
wasn't so much on policy because as a
President Reagan wrote his memoirs in
which he says but he eventually let
Alexander hit go not because the
differences on policy but because he
could not accept the fact that the
president was in charge of foreign
policy and so the personality clash what
would your relationship to our higher
very cool and distant because Hague did
not want people like myself in the white
house still have any influence and
foreign policy and there was a constant
tension here and between the White House
Reagan White House on the State
Department so where were you in what was
your job inside wife I was director of
East European and Soviet affairs and the
National Security Council so
theoretically my job was to get the
feedback from all the agencies and the
executives a particular State and
Defense get the memoranda to the
president summarize them and give my
recommendations but it didn't work like
that at all because any secretary can
call up the president talk to him
directly or visit him bypassing the NAC
process altogether so in effect my job
was to comment on various events for the
president right memoranda foreign help
writing speeches and things of that sort
we're always watching Colin Powell the
Secretary of State and Condoleezza Rice
and national security council director
that chief talk about the relative
emailed State Department's over a
twenty-third Street yeah White House is
it sixteenth Street it's seven blocks
apart well where's the NSC where's the
national security cam National Security
Council physical token of the old
executive building which is right next
to date to the White House it was once
the war department but because it is the
White House selfish but it into space
the National Security Advisor himself or
herself have offices in the White House
but the staff is in across in the old
executive office building well the
Kendall cannot be tension it depends
what the president is what the president
wants in general and the State
Department
is opposed to use of force that is they
just consider the resort to force to
mean failure of policy in foreign policy
the White House it differs in some
president the president reagan and
george w bush resort to force is
considered to be alright if necessary
but if the president is like Reagan or
george w bush then you have this
constant tension because the state
department's always discuss things and
greetings act mode and multinational ii
and so on three united nations we always
went an intention with the State
Department how did you find yourself in
the first place inside the Reagan White
House well because of Team B I became
rather well known as a critic of the
talent and the general strike the Soviet
Union and Richard V Allen was a member
of the committee on the present danger
invited me to join the committee and
present danger and then we got to know
each other and then finale we cannot
secure advisor he asked me to join his
staff what was the committee on present
danger and who sponsored that chameleon
the present danger was something formed
in 76 about the same time as Team B by
people like Eugene Rostow Paul Nitze to
alert American public to the fact that
we're falling behind in our defense
posture that the Soviets are overtaking
it and we raised alarm about that and
the continued love of success President
Reagan was a member of the committee not
only bored of humidity all of the
committee and present danger but he was
a member of it and he I think was very
much influenced by it when we're going
through a period now where people reach
back five six seven years and find a
group of people in the new American
Century that were very much in support
of going in and getting Saddam Hussein
it a similar thing like the Committee on
present danger as president reagan
became president you moved into the
White House to influence him well the
equipment and the president danger ism
were dinner such a specific task it just
was saying look to the nation we are
falling behind in our defensive posture
and we must do something about it and
that has bigger percussions in detention
why did you think that well because the
evidence was pointing this way we follow
very closely Soviets build-up
particularly in strategic nuclear
weapons the
up on the Navy submarines and so on and
we felt their racing forward and this in
face of the assumption of our defense
specialists that in the nuclear age
security is meaningless obviously they
operate on 10 different premise and that
premise was that you can fight it and
win a nuclear war now who would have
been on the other side of what your
position was and what would they be
called virtually everybody put the other
side they hold the mythological
community and all the Defense Committee
there were mainly arms controllers
people who believe that the tension can
be diffused by arms control measures
what's a Soviet would you call Soviet
ologist what Scientologists was in
eulogies and then form meeting people
exploits on the Soviet Union yeah but so
are you I don't like the term but I was
regarded as a yes what's the difference
between the revisionists and the
traditionalist what that applies to
historical learning that is nothing to
do with defense postures I describe this
in my book the difference between people
who regarded the Soviet regime as
illegitimate as one has come to power by
coup d'etat the division is following
rather the Soviet lead said no this
regime came to power impelled by popular
support and is popular in stable and
your position on how the Soviet Union
became what it was it was a coup d'etat
it was a power seizure carried off at
night I knocked over 1917 so why do you
think that way and so many of the people
and the academia think the other way
well that's very differently to answer I
think I'm more realistic than they are
and I think the reason for revision
history geography Russian history
ography would later it arose in the
1960s it has a lot to do with policy
because there was an air of the town and
it was but many people regarded our our
my view which was shared by some
historians to be in conflict with the
towns I mean you cannot speak about a
country who is your partner and if we
want to live on good terms that he came
to power by force legitimately in a coup
d'etat so the feeling was that we've got
to be nice to these people when
say that they are a popular regime they
came to power because popular popular
support and and enjoyed popular support
now the revision was destroyed when the
sufficient collapse overnight without
any popular resistance you said when
them former senator scoop Jackson died
they had a big impact on me who was it
and why did it have an impact well a
scoop Jackson was in leading Democratic
senator from the state of Washington he
was a man of great intelligence and I'd
like many other Democrats he was very
critical of the Soviet Union and had a
pursuit about the hard line and he likes
some things I said in wrote and he made
me consultant to his committee and I
admired him very much and when he died
my ties to the democratic party with a
mushy loosens you were a Democrat then I
was a nominal I still AM I'm still a
registered Democrat I've never changed
parties and I no longer sympathize the
Democratic Party how do you define your
views in politics now yes well I'm a
conservative I believe I between force
of tradition I believe in maintaining
institutions intact of course not
rigidly and changing with time but I
think when you confront the situation
we're in a a tradition or institution is
being questioned you should always ask
yourself we would benefit by changing it
so I'm a traditionalist that way why do
you stay a Democrat I have to tell you
frankly I was going to switch parties
when I went to the White House and I had
a telephone call from the journalists we
said that we understand that you were
Democrats I said yes it's true i'm a
democrat amazing jackson Democrat and
when I hang out by said if I now change
parties who look like opportunities I
want to make a career in the Republican
Party so I just stayed well and the
years that you were in the White House
were 81 82 the first two years of Aegon
another name is prominent today in the
news who worked with richard webbing
would work with scoop Jackson is Richard
Perle yeah explain I mean it was he a
member of the democratic party van and
was do you know him very well I know I'm
quite well I I met him just about the
time all day why should we know so to
treaty he invited me he in Dorothy fall
sick invited to testify and so true to
treat in the early 70s yes
quite well he is a neoconservative he's
a Democrat I don't think he changed
parties speaking of salt to you had
something to do with the name start yeah
and what is that and what did you have
to do is well we were discussing the NSC
abandon give you the term salt was
strategic arms limitation talks because
the president wanted to reduce nuclear
weapons so the question was what you
come up with and nothing seemed to be
right when I came up this popped in my
head is environment called spark
strategic arms reduction talks and that
was accepted I want to show you a short
video clip from a previous book notes a
couple of years ago and see if you
recognize that's all let's roll the tape
my political education was in college I
was in college from 1967 271 Harvey
Harvard years of rage and revolution and
I thought they were mistaken and taking
that position arguing against the
radicals was my clinical education I was
all the time wondering why I'm in this
tiny minority that's against the
revolution what's your father's politics
not too different for mine how much
impact did he have on the way well again
you know it's no doubt he had impact but
at the same time there are many other
fathers whose politics were similar to
mine and their children were radicals so
I'll take some credit and that man is my
son Daniel is with a Middle Eastern
expert and he does work on the Middle
East now he's particularly concerned
with the terrorist movement and militant
Islam and indeed as some of the same
things that I and said some of the same
things that I did I said about communism
so worthy above captured contrariness
maybe genetic I don't know I feel that I
have been vindicated by events and I
think she probably with nekid by Vince
too I generally agree with him I think a
lot of illusions about militant Islam in
this country and all of unwarranted
feeling of smugglers and security now I
want to go back I want to read a quote
here from your book on my butt I want to
go back to your end the white house for
a couple years your part
the National Security Council and you
say it's not like it looks like from the
outside and it how did you then and did
you then influence the president
announced States in any way I think I
did Ronald Reagan photos anti-communism
was in some ways very naive about it he
had this notion that the Soviet leaders
are misguided by philosophy of Marxist
which is wrong and they have the heart
of hearts they have the well-being and
happiness of their subjects or the
citizens and that if you just sit down
with him and explain to them why Marxism
is wrong and our philosophy of democracy
and free market is right they would
change and everything be fine and I to
persuade him and I succeeded eventually
though these people do not wish the
happiness and well being a citizen is
because their power and the privileges
restaurant subjugation of these people
the Russia is ruled by no mentira my
class of privilege officials who cannot
allow their people the kind of freedoms
that we enjoy and it took he's such a he
was such a kind man and he just couldn't
understand this he just wouldn't go to
his head that people don't wish world
own citizens but finally I think he got
the message and towards the very end
when I left the White House who I
remember him saying in someone on some
occasion no I no longer believe they
have the well-being of the citizens at
heart they really are privileged group
and they think differently from us you
were hard by Richard Allen Dick Allen
who is there as a national security
adviser how long not quite a year just
about a year hehe i think resigned
either december of 81 or general 82 had
a heat treat you well he treated me well
I were great deal to him we had some
problems sometimes but you do right in
here about the fact he didn't want you
to get any credit for anything you wrote
I felt that way but not only me but
anybody else on the anar Security
Council yeah I think he he did not
forward to the president our memoranda
our opinions written opinions in our
name he was all anonymous there was his
policy it was not the policy of a
successor judge Clark
why did he only stay a year when he the
extensible reason was if you remember
the scandal he was very unfairly treated
by the administration when the
administration came in mrs. Reagan was
interviewed by Japanese magazine and
when the interview was over as a custom
they handed her some money in an
envelope as a team with a thousand
dollars and Dick intercepted this money
and give it a Secretary's putting it
safe and then a year later well closer
you later this was discovered and it was
thought it was a bribe or some money
that he concealed and I did he was
totally vindicated on this but the real
reason why he was I think this missed
because he was too conservative for the
people who were close to the president
which is mrs. Reagan and Jim Bakker and
Mike Deaver how did you know that oh we
could liquid sense it I mean I cannot
put my finger on but we knew that there
were many symptoms of this mrs. Reagan
particularly wanted him to become more
moderate in his anti-communist and why
would she want the idea an idea well I
suspect she wanted to make it with the
society in Washington which is
essentially run by liberals there's that
conniving matter to you it mattered to
me to some extent yes because when my
access to the president was very
restricted as a result of it why well
because these people felt that I was you
know in citing his anti-communism how
often did you get to see him one-on-one
and the over 101 never I used to see him
in groups in the Oval Office or other
occasions you kept a diary yeah when did
you start that in your life well I
didn't I what they had no intention to
but I I met at the beginning of my
Washington stay I ran to Scotty lesson
of the New York Times at the party and
he said now you've got to keep a journal
did be very important so I listened to
him and most every night I would sit
down and write down what happened during
the day and it came to something like
six volumes which I use in writing these
memoirs as Scotty reston would not
exactly been on your
side politically no that was knocked
upon you just said that you know for
historical purposes I should be doing
that the reason I mentioned it you were
accused of leaking information you may
retain me well along the way I mean they
didn't they suspect you leaking when you
were on the National Security Council
that people didn't like your views well
some of them did I affect us I never
least anything I considered it to be a
form of treason again what are you
feeling as a college professor at
Harvard expert on Russian the society
you're sitting inside the White House
and you're watching Dick Allen dismissed
and then who comes in in his place well
just Clark William Clark and you work
for him I work for him how was he to you
I got a very well along with him yes was
he a conservative he was quite
conservative but the big thing was that
he was very close to the president he
was a very intimate friend of the
President and the second he had no
political ambitions of his own he
chooses his sacrifice he dreamt of going
back to his ranch in California did he
care whether your name was in a memo or
not in Kyoto so you've already got a
change in personality again you go back
to the name personality but go to Al
Haig he's Secretary of State how often
do you see him in a meeting I slamming
Tennessee meetings whenever he was
president which was most of the time I
saw him but I was a silent witness that
was a note taker or an observer let me
read what you wrote in your diary on
january early january nineteen
eighty-two this is you're near the end
of your time no no it's the middle in
the middle I'm sorry and reflections on
my first year in Washington which I
jotted down in my journal on January the
first I wrote of Hague as follows a
tactician with very limited horizons
smart on details personality disturbed
in some way what did you mean by that
look in some ways politically paranoid
he thought i mentioned an example of it
i can read it go ahead his behavior at
NSC meetings alternates between
impassioned and often accusatory
outburst and sneering silence I think he
considers himself the only man in the
room will understand the issues of
foreign policy in regards the rest
president included as nincompoops how
often by the way to use that word minkum
he flatters the president but Ronald
Reagan feels very uncomfortable with
especially when caught in a crossfire
between Hague sitting on his right and
Weinberg on his left it is difficult to
see how he can survive the whole
presidential term he has no support in
the cabinet that was January of 1982 how
long did he survive another half a year
how did he leave under what
circumstances and he leave yeah well
there were there were I don't know
specific problem there were many
problems because he handed in his
resignation many times and they were
rejected in this case they came back
from France where those a meeting
international meeting at which a
apparently behavior incidentally to mrs.
Reagan and that infuriated everybody on
the staff and he went once again and
yang gave his letter of resignation to
the president expecting to be rejected
but it wasn't accepted energy left you
felt the need in your book to tell us
that you were in meetings Ronald Reagan
and you never fought so I'm fall asleep
no why would you need to say that
because people believe Akhil isn't
normally would fall asleep at meetings
he didn't know what was going on it's
just absolutely untrue he was perfectly
alert he didn't speak very much
generally except when he's very
impassioned when the Polish crisis
erupted you know the martial law was
involved he was furious and he delivered
impassioned speeches of the NAC but
normally he listened and we'll ask a
question but didn't say very much like a
certain was alert now you mentioned the
Polish crisis that obviously was near
and dear to your heart why what I'm born
in Poland I was raised in Poland and I
feel in some respects to let fall but
this was a very traumatic experience
because the events in Poland and the
Solidarity seem to suggest the community
can evolve gradually without any and
without a war and without a crash and
that was so stopped and the Soviets
showed that they will not tolerate then
they shown it before in Hungary the
shoulder before in Java Kia but we
thought in case of Poland they will
allow it and they forced the energetics
key to impose very cruel Marshall oh and
that incense the president has incensed
me as well and what was the timing on
this even when it occurred yes what is
action and position martial law is
December 13 1981 and you
the NSA oh yeah and then exactly what
did you do and well you see it just so
happened that Adam was unlivable absence
and Clark did not come in yet so there
was no knife security advisor so I was
in a very powerful position to give
advice and my main advice was don't
don't forget to post Poland lived on the
foreign occupation 125 years and revived
and posed on the poles are different and
the post will once more coming out on
top so support them and that was
followed some extent we gave a lot of
assistance in the post what about the
sanctions question well the sanctions
were also imposed on but out of that
worked out i mean again what was your
role another funny i was told to put
their manual sanctions I did have fungus
notion talk to about it so I asked for
some advice and then I started listing
things which were inferred from Poland
or thinks facilities would use the pole
such as fishing rights landing lights of
the planes and so on and presented it to
the judge Clark could keep it in to the
president and what's one more action
enforce so what was the idea behind
thanks I mean this is always a big
discussion and whether you're for or
against well to punish to punish the
Russians in the first place because we
knew very well that Marshall was imposed
on the Russian pressure so there was
there was a presence idea they were
punishment for it and punish the pose as
well and the idea always was it to the
we said to the post if you lift the
martial law and start behaving properly
with this command then help you do you
think sanctions work well I was in a
conference a few years ago where the
generals SEOs president this was a
conference in Poland and he defended
himself it was very strange conference
because then one hand and one side of
the table satya luzinski on the other
sighs SAT Marshall kulikov the end of
the Warsaw Pact which was supposed to
invade Poland Young says she said I
imposed martial law to save poland from
the soviet invasion or worse the pact
invasion kulikov said we had no
intention of invading it was a very
interesting confrontation but he also
says he also said that the sanction cost
poland 12 billion dollars which in
positions is enormous sum of money
it's hard to say whether they worked but
they were inevitable because we had no
other means of showing our displeasure I
mean we could not use military power so
basically economic means we're the only
means we had and I was called in favor
of that so if there wasn't a national
security advisor at the time and you
were the direct you have direct memo
access to the resilience at the time I
did do those tools against our sanctions
commerce was against commerce to
partners because of trade come here
Treasury I'm not sure about CIA I don't
remember this now this is 20 years but
the heaven and the whole certainly
weinberger secretary defense was for it
and Jim Kirkpatrick goes for it Hague
vacillated one day he was for it next
day he was against it you find yourself
and at some time and you might remember
what the date was at the Bohemian Grove
in California which is an exclusive club
I think isn't of some kind it's an
exclusively male club and why were you
there what I was invited my friend was a
member and when was this was justin
while you were on the interstate no no
those up to us well the quote i'm going
to read his pipes I can destroy you how
by saying that I agree with you it was a
fine example of his self dep dep ritory
humor you're talking about Henry
Kissinger and what was your relationship
with him during all this well at first
it was very friendly because he tried to
get on the K into the regular
administration but then he didn't get in
because reagan did not like him and he's
related away so i used to meet him
occasionally both here and abroad at
various conferences for example visible
conference i met him and you know we
talked and so on but he was not involved
in policy know what do you what his
position I mean had you to agree on not
if I criticized him because he was the
author was the architect of the town and
I was very critical of the time too
because I thought the rest of a false
premise of what the Soviet Union isn't
worried setting define what did tante
was and who started it what I think it
actually was started in Germany by the
sauce politics the notion that if you
are friendly to the Russians
if you start engaging in not on the arms
limitation talks but in trade
collections so on that country will
eventually soften instance the premise
was that Russians are paranoid because
they've been invaded so many times and
they are always insecure so if you
threaten them they become hard line and
dangerous if you're nice to them they'll
they'll become no reciprocate and our
return policy was based on something
rather similar similar premise my
argument was that historically speaking
first of all the rational did not were
not only invaded we also did some
invading you don't become the greatest
largest country in the world by being
invaded they did a lot of invading and
conquering secondly the historically
speaking Russians were always most
aggressive when they felt most secure
the only time when they're really clock
hitting potential enemies was during the
pack from the Nazi Germany because
they're mortally afraid of Hitler so
between 39 and 41 they were pleasing in
every possible way so I thought the
targets on a very false premise I would
say and they and our opponents said no
if you want to be harsh on the Russians
they will they will reciprocate in kind
and you're going to get another stunning
in fact we were totally wrong because we
got Gorbachev you you say in your book
and I you can correct me on this but you
say every time we went to the Soviet
Union you couldn't wait to get out of
the country there was not only my
feelings almost every Western I felt
that way what first of all the
atmosphere of fear the atmosphere was
spying particular if you spoke Russian
as I did my telephones were tapped in
the early years particularly i was
always followed everywhere I went and
that was just very very unpleasant we
were not used to that how often have you
been there and when was the first time
you went I went in 57 the first time
which was four years after studies death
then the 59 60 62 I lectured at
University of Leningrad and I went to
every few years and there was a long
hiatus I did not go because I work for
the government then I started like that
and now I'm very welcome there but when
you go there gnatios feel the same way
they can't wait hold on oh no no it's
totally different now now the atmosphere
is no spying no tapping of telephones
nope
here i lecture freely I write freely and
in fact in some circles and we got as a
kind of hero I just residents Russian
magazine cuz vs died yesterday I got
this num number and they refer to me as
somebody who made a major contribution
to the destruction of the Soviet system
but which will always be grateful to it
well that's a big change when how many
books have you written in your life I
think 21 and how many I'm on Russia well
virtually all except for this book and a
textbook of Western European
civilization they're all I Russia and
how much impact did you have during the
time when the Communists were in control
in Russia how much do they read what you
said and how often were you able to tell
him exactly in person what you thought
was the truth well in person this was
not really possible in Soviet days it is
you couldn't because they just endanger
the people you talk to but my books were
red in fact someone were translated in
by the office by by the muddy government
particularly my when I enter the
government they started translating my
writing so they can know what my views
were and I know I heard from some
Russians that I became some enemy number
one and that was especially true after I
contributed the President's speech the
circle westminster speech which
libertine 82 in london where he said
marks was right when he said that when
the political system in the economic and
social system out of step the country's
new revolution situation but that
applies to the Soviet Union not to us
and when they read that and they knew
that I contributed then they climbed up
the wall because it's the first time the
American president criticized the system
traditionally our presidents criticized
Soviet behavior and our policy was we
don't really care what your system is
you have whatever you like if that's
what you like okay but don't become
aggressive and we've acted on the kind
of premise of behavioral psychology that
if you slap them in long enough and
often enough for them is behavior they
will start behaving if my argument was
no that's not so you tell story about
what you did when Brezhnev died
yes what was it give me when I went
through the yes the embassy went to the
embassy well yes I go to the embassy too
because the present was going to come to
the next day so when do the security
people to look at and don't bring in who
is the ambassador took me to the room
where there was a book of condolences
and thrusts the pen in my hand and I
should know no thanks Ryan no no you
must so I scribbled something somewhere
nobody could recognize my signatures the
future excuse me for policy why is that
well I shall know no sorrow at Britain's
death but how did the president handle
his he knows very well I was asked to
write what he's supposed to put a
netbook and I just couldn't do it
because you know if you don't believe
something we can write properly and
you've handled very well he's crossed
out what I wrote and wrote his own
condolences which had to do many of the
family and so on was very very well
tactfully put so why did you leave the
White House I had to if I want to keep
my Harvard share common only gives you
two years of leave of absence no matter
how high you are didn't Henry Kissinger
getting longer than that what he did but
he gave up his have a chair so would you
have stayed longer if you didn't have to
I would not why not hi I sort of had
enough and I found myself limitlessly
constrained by my working in a large
organization and not being in myself
when I'm at Harvard professor i'm a
master of myself i can teach what i want
i can teach what I want and nobody
questions what I say I hold my office
hours when I want I'm totally free
person and here is a government does in
any large organization they tell me
constraint and i found this difficult we
paint a picture again going back to the
atmosphere than being in the old
executive office building having your
own office did it matter where your
office was located at who added this yes
you had to the prime prime real estate
was an office that looked at the White
House then next one was pennsylvania
avenue then on the street the worst was
in the courtyard nobody wanted that but
if you had if you had one on the White
House and a balcony that was prime real
estate I had I had a few of the white
husband no no no balcony still this is
very
the real estate did you find yourself
maneuvering trying to get in to see the
president I couldn't do it trying to get
credit for what you're going to it you
couldn't I was told by his right a
little I think I described an incident
for a friend of mine was long experience
in Washington asked me to see the
Nationals here advisor I think was Clark
and I called the secretary and she said
what he's busy right now but I write it
down and then she called again I called
her again and she said he's busy in my
friend called and said what did you see
him i said no i called his secretaries
and she said he's really cuz we don't do
it that way just go down and put your
foot on the door and getting a bit
better look I cannot do it I'm just not
used to it so what did it feel like when
two years were up and you were back at
Harvard well on one hand it was sinus I
I he decide relieved then I was a few
min again and I go back to scholarship
on the other hand I I thought gray
gratitude to Alan and Clark but they
kept me there but I learned a lot about
politics and it affected very much the
wave of my history okay what you learn
well again I go back to the issue
personalities I was running his to the
Russian volution before i went there and
i finished it later on and there was an
episode in Russian history when Nicholas
the second ballasts are dismissed his
minister to give it a prime minister
very long very capable minister and I
couldn't say why and contemporary said
that he did it because he couldn't bear
his manners he was crude he wasn't
towered over him his retro man telegram
is very crude and he had reputation he
married a lady wasn't quite socially
acceptable he chewed gum it was said I
said that could not be and then I saw
the ass and I saw Reagan than hey guy
said yes these things do happen
personally at all and I also realize how
often decisions are made just ad hoc you
know we will invade will not invade it's
sometimes as simple as that a small
story you tell about George Shultz when
your he was a new Secretary of State and
you were in the room and you were
sitting there and what did he do to you
what he was uncomfortable because he
didn't know me and I was taking notes
suggest i do this automatically he had a
conversation with the President and he
said he said this is very sensitive if
it leaked out be very unpleasant
and he then stare that means that you
taking those makes me uncomfortable and
the Clark said well we've met mr. pipes
of me on the council for many years and
he's very reliable but he was very
hostile to me what do you think of him
well I think he was far more stable
personality name was Hague and but he
also performed the role of a sexual
stage which was to try to bring the
president away from his anti-communist
and Torres more accommodating role and
he tried and succeeded in the end but of
course what really made the difference
was the advent of Gorbachev the
president would did not soften his
stance even though she was under
pressure from from shorts tourists the
solution until Gorbachev came in and
then he made got much of in Geneva I was
there but not as a government official
but rather with I think he's a CBS or
NBC and barely warm towards each other
and then gradually as we can so
Gorbachev's genuine human being and
liberal he changes policy you you
mentioned something earlier it kind of
flew by but it's in your book also but
anybody we get a lot of calls on our
Comment show hearing it will say aha and
that's you went to a Bilderberg meeting
yes and there are three or four things
that people think are part of conspiracy
trilateral commission the Council on
Foreign Relations and the Bilderbergers
it's nonsense why is it nonsense well
because I attended I'm member of the
Council for relations and I tended to
Bilderberg meetings accounts of
relations is this color the Institute
and you know with his reputation being
very liberal but I'm here I am I'm a
conservative and I lecture to it and I
vote for the Foreign Affairs it's
official organ and so on and secondly
Bilderberg well those are very exclusive
meetings they take place once a year in
different locations some 100 100 people
attend and again I attended these two
meetings and I have lectures people
speaking about this entry big thing
about that and I nobody tried to make
policy and nobody cooks part about
anything people say that everybody is
all part of the same group they all get
together had these meetings make money
off the system you know
it's all part of being in the number of
group Kissinger and David rock up around
this and I surely don't shake it don't
share their political views and yet i
was i was there so which intrepid Rick
there are a couple of names when I asked
you about way off the subject Nietzsche
is one of them and montane is another
they they played a role in your life or
a friend if Nisha played a role in my
youth because he encouraged my
rebellious lets you know all teenagers
are a video some videos and he said be
yourself ravel and I like them but then
as I grew older I found him unbearable I
finally just so irresponsible what he
said is so dramatic in many ways but he
I never read him after I baqi I just
pull it Montaigne is somebody for older
age I tried Montana at the age of 13 I
couldn't like it and now I adore him why
he's very wise man extremely wise when
did he live early 16th century and his
essays on one of the greatest books ever
written but I don't advise any of you
listeners to read it before 50 because
it's a council moderation he's a
moderate man and a man who has no
illusions about life and what you can
achieve be yourself he tell with you but
not in the way nature did be himself but
be moderate don't aspire to too much he
says in one of his essays he said you
know no matter how high you climb even
from his phone he ultimately sit on your
own rump you know is this kind of thing
I love it well there is one example in
the book where he talks about what you
should do later in life about studying
and reading and yeah you know you should
give it up this I did not follow why
would he say that I don't know this is a
peculiarity he was a skeptic in general
above life and he felt of course what's
old age then in what say of days now
differs he probably wrote this when he
was in his 50s he was concerned smoke
and relax enjoy life I I tried not to
study and not to not to write and I and
went out of my mind are you still gonna
do more oh I'm doing a big book now and
history of reference thought and your ad
I mating this and you professor emeritus
at Harvard do you teach at all anymore
no I lecture around the country and in
Europe but I I no teacher so when did
you leave Poland and why well I left
Poland at the age of 16 when the Germans
invaded in September 1939 my father knew
what was good to expect on the German
occupation and miraculously procures
Babu's South American passports which we
left Poland some in the first train that
left until the assertion German troop
train and we made our way through
Germany we spent two days in Germany and
then went to Italy and from there made
our way to America eventually we're
gendered in America when where my
parents ended up in a small town upstate
New York admire in New York when my
father opened a small chocolate factory
hehe manufacturing chocolates in Poland
and I went to college in Ohio where
muskingum college Muskegon Caillat
Edward steady not City village you
conquered and why there because he gave
me fellowship and they gave me a chance
to earn money my father could only give
me two hundred dollars and I got a
fellowship from them right a chance to
work for thirty-five cents an hour and
you know you're the only famous graduate
is John Glenn we were were they at the
same time and how long did you stay
that's it in my junior year in the
junior year I tried to volunteer for the
for the armed services but it wouldn't
take me with as a foreign citizen and
then eventually they drafted me and I
have a choice not to go into the service
which case of Leonard we have become an
American citizen or to enroll and I did
enter this service and I was because I
spoke three languages they sent me to
learn a force in in Russian and he said
Miller Cornell and that determine my
whole lives because I became a Russian
expert due to this education what trip
did for them to think that you should
learn Russian well we had air bases in
the Ukraine protocol
bombing our bomber is stationed in
England and Italy could not reach East
Germany or Poland and bomb they had to
refuel so the Russians agreed to give us
bases in the Ukraine with this planes
landed refuel we loaded with bombs and
came back and bombed on the way back so
they needed American officers who could
converse with him but then by the time I
graduated in cornell from this Russians
course the tide of war had turned and
stalin didn't want in Russian speaking
Americans so another one so when the war
was over where'd you go I went to
Harvard Graduate School inherit to work
for a PhD and did you get your
undergraduate degree at Cornell hakuna
and when did you meet Irene at Cornell I
was in the Army and she is also from
Poland we in fact lived as children four
blocks away and I parents knew each
other did you know her then in Poland we
figured we attended some birthday
parties children and so who hooked you
up together at Cornell was actually our
professor of Russia when the process of
Russian who brought a recording how very
pleasant female voice reading my polish
poetry and I became interested in one
thing led to another what year did you
marry the maiden 46 and how many
children do you have we have to since we
met Daniel earlier and the other is
steven is a hotel manager in New York
City and why professor of Russian
history for the rest of your life what
was it about that that really grabbed
you well it was a very open field you
know when i began my graduate work i
wasn't so determined on studying Russian
but I got I got hooked on it because for
30-some years basically all history
writing about Russia was controlled by
the communist party with all you know
highly biased almost all the professors
of Russian history in this country were
foreigners many of them Russian
immigrants so those tremendous
opportunity for us and by the time I got
my doctorate there was an absolutely
open field you could write on any
subject you wanted on Russia today this
is no longer true and i was very
exciting i mean if you were in English
history
this is very much a good of done but
Russian history was just absolutely an
open book in 1960 you had a dinner of
some kind for George Kennan I saw a
Berlin Arthur slaving her I may have
missed one in yourself you know who was
your force but it was hidden as lesson
to Edmund Wilson Edmund Wilson yeah and
you have pictures in the book of isaiah
berlin let's just talk about these
characters you have some strong things
to say about each one of them what about
who was George Kennan and what did you
think of him well George Kennan was
America's leading expert on the Soviet
Union politically in the during the
early stages of the cold war hero the
famous article in foreign affairs I'm
mr. X in which he explained what the
solution was after he shattered some of
the delusions which were created during
the war particularly during the relation
with in relationship between President
Roosevelt and studying hits remembers
influence and our policy the whole
policy of containment basically goes
back to him I admired him tremendously
for that he later on somehow change his
mind he had an unfortunate experience in
the Foreign Service he was more or less
bumped out of it by John Foster Dulles
and he became rather embittered about
American foreign policy and I don't
alive sorry still alive oh here's about
he's in his 90s yes but he doesn't write
anymore you said he got a bit egocentric
well yeah I think he was when he had
great ambitions he wanted to be at least
likely of State and he didn't make it
because of personal clashes and I was
rather disappointed in his later career
and for example I testified with him
jointly about the Soviet invasion of
Afghanistan in 1917 in Congress and he
defended the sewage invasion as being
defensive move he became very apologetic
for the Soviet Union where was this
dinner with my house where in belmont at
the time we live in Belmont
Massachusetts yeah home of the John
Birch Society yes what years ago
go back to then I saw a Berlin was who
was he and why was a very good friend of
mine he was a native of Russia
naturalized Englishman it philosopher
very prominent intellectual he wasn't
especially said about sure but he knew a
great deal about Russia he was
essentially philosopher and we came very
friendly a great influence on me why
because of his enormous range
intellectual range you know in American
intellectual circles academic circles
you are supposed to specialize and not
range very widely let's talk about
things you not in not in future
specialty and he encouraged me with his
own broad range to speak out and to
write on subjects which are not and feel
of my specialty so I recently published
a book on property mr. property which I
you know which is not my field I did it
because I felt my studies in russia
russian history persuaded me that
property is essential to freedom and i
wrote that book i don't know i might
have written it even without his
influence but he wasn't influential well
you make a point in your book about the
importance of understanding property
what is the value of understanding
property to the whole world power
historically speaking you can have
political freedom and human rights only
in societies in which society not the
government control the bulk of the
wealth because if the modem or wealth
the government controls the more
Cavaliere can be of human rights and the
Soviet Union was a perfect example to
control all the productive wealth and
our experience shows the English expands
to begin with in American experience
that if society control the wealth and
gamma is dependent on society for money
then our rights are guaranteed Edmund
Wilson who was he when he was America's
leading literary critic what was he like
he was known as bunny he was brilliant
man I loved him he he was he had been in
the thirties very nice about the Soviet
Union he wrote some very pro-soviet
books and he'd after was admitted to me
they kid made a mistake but he was a
great literary critic and any man who
when I admired particularly for the fact
that even when I knew him he was already
in his 70s he was like a young man
continuously willing to learn
he started learning Hungarian a very
difficult language at that age and I i
think i may have favored from him under
his influence but even i'm 80 and still
willing to learn new things here's i
don't know that i can find it but there
was a quote in here about you he he had
a routine that people were coming after
him what would i would he prevent me
from getting too well people of course
wasn't come to him to recommend their
books and review their books because
they would review from Edmund Wilson
could make a book he was book reviewer
for me for The New Yorker so he'll they
would send in minor scrapes and so on
and he had a hidden red red postcard ok
give me a copy of it we had all kinds of
places to check out mr. Wilson regrets
he does not give interviews he does not
review unsolicited manuscripts he
doesn't attend teas and spent literate
ease and so on and so forth but it
scared people and Arthur slicing it was
your last guest at this dentist and by
the way what was your reason for trying
to get all these people together my
reason was I thought I'd get you the
four first-rate minds together a dinner
in our house and I'll just sit back and
enjoy brilliant conversation well as
I've wrote in the book it didn't turn
out that way because they all were used
to being prima donnas center of
attention and the conversation did not
flow at all I was very disappointed but
you trying to find a quote I can't but
is it was an interesting quote about how
they're all such individuals that they
all wanted to do all the talking yes
well if they were sitting in the
presence of other similar stars they
just couldn't get them supposed to talk
so I was not a memorable evening throws
it is that by was memorable you remember
you're right about yes as well because I
was so disappointed in it how individual
TV show this man had wonderful
conversations how do you approach
writing what's your style well normally
this is an exception I mean this is a
book where I right from memory or for my
Diaries but what have I scholarly books
if I have an interest in the subject i'm
going to read primary and secondary
sources i make notes and any thoughts
that come to my mind I've write down and
I do short drafts because I find it is
too much time elapses from the time I
read something then the intention is
and then when the time comes to write I
we've all these things together are you
still keeping a diary no I know people
that this book is published by Yale
press yeah how often does Yale press
publish a Harvard professor well my case
that's the third time because it's my
third book published by then what's your
a best-selling book of all time out of
over over 20 books I think probably rush
under the old regime which I published
30 years ago blandford and Nicholson in
England and scribners here has been in
print consumed numerous numerous
editions by the penguin books now and it
because it is a survey Russian history
and it's using courses and so as it so
this problem is how many of your books
are still in print I can say but I think
almost all the important books the major
books are in print except some special
monographs such as and the Russian labor
movement and the Russian asst historian
amazeen knees out of print but the
others almost all imprint you say I was
always more interested in wisdom than
knowledge what does that mean well I
mean I I am NOT interested in in
knowledge that doesn't teach you
anything about life you know the some
people are they just want to know I want
to know I won't understand life I
understand how to behave how to act what
is wisdom and that comes across from
study but a lot of studies in relevant
to it so I don't study things which are
relevant and I always want to get at the
heart of the only thing they thing would
teach me wisdom you say people did not
make history they make a living yes like
what do you mean by that well I mean you
know there's a school of historians who
believe that the history is made from
below it's made by the masses and I I
know it bought some personal experience
watching the war in Europe and from
studying history that most people have
to even in the worst because
circumstances have to go back to making
a living feeling their family doing the
laundry and doing all these things and
they cannot engage in politics they can
do it for 24 hours around the barricades
but politics from day to day has to be
done to professionals so I oppose the
history from the law school because I
think history general but particularly
non democratic societies is made from
the more
you say you used to read the Sinclair
Lewis novels what years did you do that
and why this is rather amusing
circumstance they was during the war
when I was in the Air Force and one day
I went on and town with it would be my
colleagues path and I was topped by MPs
and they asked me for my serial number
and I didn't remember it because I never
tried to memorize it so they send me
back to the place where I'd we lived in
hotels and this was the Air Force in st.
Petersburg Florida and I was put on KP
kicks a night KP for a whole week and I
got to talking to the cook and when he
found out that I was polish he don't
forget about it so I absented myself and
I went to the here so I we got a stack
of Sinclair Lewis nervous and I hold
myself happened in that room in our
compassion in our suite and then I went
to old and I was of Lewis again vixi
means i have lived and here is the cover
of the book our guest has been Richard
pipes professor emeritus at Harvard
memoirs of a non belong ER thank you
very much for joining us